let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
our first caller is from the 5 7 1 area
code big news week very interested in
hearing what's on people's minds so 571
tell us who you are where you're calling
from and what's on your mind today
hello my name is Cory I have a good
question for you yeah as a reporter how
do you like no react or cry when you see
them like the trauma administration is
and putting kids in cages yeah and I
think I just read also that um the judge
allowed him to do that for 20 days how
is it that you don't like react
emotionally how is it that you are so
well professional on your job well and I
appreciate your job I appreciate the
question because implicit in it is a
compliment so thank you for that Grover
it's always great to hear from you I
mean listen I think the sad reality of
it is that to some degree I'm kind of
desensitized now I I don't mean I'm
desensitized politically like I still
recognize that putting kids in
internment camps cages separate you know
like all the stuff I realize the
inhumanity of it and I'm completely
horrified by it but I think on some more
visceral level I've just become used to
reporting about our government doing
really horrible things and as a result I
mean I don't know you're kind of I'm
just reporting about it and I'm telling
the audience about it and I don't
in that moment I guess have a breakdown
but I guess your point Grover seems to
be that this is really horrible stuff
and that it's kind of normalized by the
fact that it's reported on as almost
like you know GE had $2 earnings per
share 22 kids were put in cages and Elon
Musk is working on a new rocket right
like it's just cut it kind of becomes
part of the normal news it sounds like
you're saying yeah it's really bad yeah
I really appreciate for taking my call
and I hope to you keep going pokémon
thank you so much
all right Grover thank you so much
always always good to hear from Grover
and yeah I mean it's what do you have
anything to add to that
bad you should see David Affair he's an
absolute wreck I don't know how you pull
it together
ya know it's definitely a it's it's a
combination of desensitization and just
saying you know I've got to deliver the
stories I've got to talk about the news
that that it is what it is and I'm going
to do that right now